coin
uno por uno son recordados han pasado
diez años y noruega aún no se repone de
su peor atentado desde la segunda guerra
mundial el 22 de julio de 2011 el
extremista anders breivik detonó un
carro bomba frente edificios
gubernamentales matando a ocho personas
e hiriendo a decenas posteriormente se
dirigió a la isla de utoya en un bote y
disfrazado de policía abrió fuego y
asesinó a 69 personas que asistían a un
campamento de las juventudes del partido
laborista 33 eran menores en las horas
después de la detonación de la bomba en
el barrio gubernamental de muchos
pensaron que era un acto de extreme ismo
islamista y blair pero el autor era un
extremista de ultraderecha el extra
las campanas de las iglesias de oslo
redoblaron durante cinco minutos tras la
ceremonia
como no hemos detenido el odio el
extremismo de ultraderecha sigue vivo el
terrorista era uno de nosotros hair
extremis man le ha dado a los
sobrevivientes visitaron la isla de
utoya para rendir tributos a quienes ya
no están con ellos 10 años después
anders behring breivik hoy con 42 años
de edad cumple una pena de prisión de 21
años una condena prorrogables y sigue
siendo considerado un peligro para la
sociedad el ultraderechista islamófobo
nunca se arrepintió del ataque con el
que dijo pretendía salvar europa
occidental de los musulmanes y del
marxismo cultural